speaking of you know cookie cutter
manufactured
assembly line content yeah
addison ray signed a multi-picture deal
with netflix this was just announced by
the way congratulations i'm sure she's
[ __ ] thrilled right she's probably
made millions of dollars off this [ __ ]
i'm not gonna hate on someone's success
but go to um
go to the rotten tomatoes for he's all
that or she's all that or whatever wait
can i just really quickly make something
clear yeah
drake is the greatest rapper
like literally the greatest artist oh
he's not dude if there's any piece of
art that you think is better than drake
burn it
because he is literally the best i think
he's all that's better
drake should have been and he's all that
that's the only way it could have been
better
um too sexy sorry i actually kind of do
like that song i was i meant to joke
earlier that you got your big mac while
listening to i'm too sexy yeah making
your [ __ ] clap
now i'm eating it out i'm eating it
vertically
you ever eat a burger vertically and
just and just lick the cheese out of the
middle yeah always yeah
don't shudder what was that oh
we need that sound on the soundboard
can't tell if it grossed you out or made
you hard
it's like when they were murdering that
fish with carrots on twitter you
remember that no like they're jamming
carrots in its mouth and it just goes
like
that's not funny
[Laughter]
poor thing was [ __ ] dying too right
yeah and they made it gang oh want some
more yeah all right
they made its mascara run while killing
he's enjoying it
oh no
yeah
it's so [ __ ] up it makes like worse
and more in there i think it's [ __ ]
this
oh oh is this the fish murder channel
i used to talk about this way early in
the park yeah here we go oh no don't
play us can you play it without us
seeing
it just wait for it
that was it
that's not funny
it's not funny
it's not funny
[Laughter]
he throw the [ __ ] out of here
[Laughter]
that's that's the sound that's the sound
everybody made when they found out
addison ray penned a
60 bajillion dollar deal yeah
look at this so this is what i mean like
we live in a special time in history and
in entertainment where you can get like
a 24 on your movie mm-hmm and then two
weeks later sign a multi-picture deal
with the same studio yeah who put this
one out yeah they're like we don't give
a [ __ ] yeah
you know why it's not about
making good art well i mean given a lot
of netflix recent productions like
can you really expect them to do much
better
because i think they made the circle and
all those
reality shows and they were like they
looked at those budgets and thought holy
[ __ ] this is sick yeah that's true the
shows cost 20 and they get this many
subscribers
yeah yeah hell yeah
we don't need to be a24 we need money
yeah so this movie actually trended
number one in like a bunch of countries
it pulled in so many signups for
netflix austin mcbroom should have put
her on the card maybe that would have
saved him
from bankruptcy addison ray
congratulations you know it's good to
see
diversity
good to see diversity in
in the talent here at netflix
i just watched the talk about
[ __ ]
[Music]
a horribly [ __ ] up documentary about
some french woman who was killed in
ireland okay
[ __ ] was like that's not funny
no it's not
[Laughter]
i'm laughing because you go into this
and you're like there's gonna be a
payoff no it's one of those where you
get to the end and you're like well
you're like life's dark yeah you see
that tweet god i forget who it was but
it was like it's crazy that serial
killers in the 70s had no idea that they
were just going around creating content
how many ted bundy shits do we need you
saw they're making another no i know
with the stop remaking [ __ ] we don't
care we don't care we get it he killed
college girls the matrix now
oh yeah come on
so the fans got stuck for that but
we don't need it stop tarnishing the
legacy of these wonderful franchises
here's a tick tock clip right here ready
do you want do you know the fan theory
for the new matrix resurrection movie
dude what is it man
okay the theory is in one scene in the
trailer
the original matrix can be seen playing
on a projector so the thought is that
neo the one comes back and he's like an
actor who played in a movie called the
matrix that's within the matrix and he
keeps having these dreams about all
these powers and this therapist is like
no these are just in your head from
doing the film
turns out this [ __ ] can actually
do these things
and he is the one
that's the rough idea okay hold on you
guys superman you lost me so meta i
didn't follow that at all
so in the trailer got it okay
it can be seen okay
in one scene right
that the original matrix is playing on a
projector got you so he he was an actor
and did that movie yes with but within
the match
that they're in is within the matrix
okay
so he's the one he did a movie about the
matrix in the matrix yeah but he doesn't
know that he's the one
so coincidentally he also just so
happens to be the one yeah he also
played the one in a movie yes within
the matrix where he was he's also the
one so
that cannot be true
i mean in the trailer like he's like
talking to a therapist there's like
someone who appears to be his agent he
like runs into trinity and he's like
he's like hey and she's like do we know
each other it's like clearly he knows
her from his dreams
and he's like reconnecting with all
these people and then
there's like a rebooted morpheus
something like that
that's lame
i know
i hope that's not true because that
sucks
you haven't even seen the movie yet how
can you have an opinion yeah blue pill
yeah
yeah sick yeah
yeah if that's what it is i'm
i'm
already let down i know but i'll give it
a shot you know because
i love the matrix
we're just at a weird point uh with
entertainment you see the
the mtv music awards or the video awards
whatever the vmas
i was like
30 percent
less watched than last year what was the
stat yeah i was like 16 this scored less
than a million viewers
on mtv down 31
wow no one like no one is this is like
the last year of this [ __ ] actually
being
i mean it can't be profitable anymore
can't it
it's an award show but yeah probably not
yeah i heard like 65 of the viewers were
eating chicken nuggets while they
watched it
just making them stats
wow that's crazy whatever that says
about the whole landscape i'm not sure i
heard like 93 of the audience has feet
really yeah seven percent are dogs
dogs have feet
or feetless dogs no they're dogs
legs according to soundscan paws don't
count his feet
so it's like some old tv thing they
won't count dogs as viewers
what do you call um
a cow with no legs
ground beef
nicely
[Applause]
nice thank you
[Laughter]
damn 31 though is pretty
pretty rough less than a million views
less than a million people
me and the vmas have something in
common hit that one with a laugh too
[Applause]
this is five second delay
um
hey
[Applause]
vmas algorithm kicking your ass too
you